the sequins are scattered and the
feathers are flying it must be time for
another new season of Dancing With the
Stars hey everyone I'm Lanna gilera for
et now on Monday night the new Dancing
with the Stars cast hits the ballroom
stage for the very first time and it was
definitely one of the most entertaining
season premieres we've seen in a very
long time former DWTS Pro Julian Huff
took her place as the show's newest
judge and she brought her firsthand
expertise to the table as well as some
serious Assets in a very low cut white
dress so which of the season 19
contestants have emerged as the Front
Runners and which one of the dancers
should just run away let's break down
the night's best and worst
performances if you thought that Fresh
Prince of Bel A's Alfonso Riviera only
had one dance move up his sleeve you're
in for a huge
surprise
oh
monkey the actor delivered the best
dance of the night with his high energy
Jive and scored the highest total of the
night as well
nine Bruno tomoni nine there you go our
top scorer of the night 36 out of 40 for
Alonso and Whitney in fact Alonso is
only the fourth contestant in Dancing
with the Stars history to receive
straight NES from the judges on his very
first
night oh loo that dance was a serious no
no the Olympian was by far the most
awkward dancer of the night and although
she tried to blame her blah chaa on a
technical mishap it was clear that the
nerves of the first night scared her
[Music]
stiff absolutely I make no excuses I
make no excuses it was awful I'm
surprised I even was able to get back
with
it stie Robinson is definitely one to
watch out for this little duckling
seriously impressed us when she shook
her stuff in a chaa set to Katy car
smash summer hit
birthday I'll you
[Music]
T in fact her perfectly placed footwork
and fast shaking hips earned her and her
dancing partner mark Bas a solid 34
[Music]
points and back to the not so great we
hate to say it because we adore Betsy
Johnson but this designer's dance was a
disaster a prop malfunction with a row
of feather boas caused the 72-year-old
blond to wind up with the lowest total
of the night with a mere 25
points there you
go
and who needs a hoverboard when you can
glide like Leah
[Music]
Thompson together
forever the Back to the Future star
proed that she is most definitely still
a babe on the dance floor with her
elegant box chot I thought that was the
one of the best first Fox shots I've
ever seen so now we want to know who was
your favorite dancer of the night tell
me your thoughts on Twitter using the #
now and for more of the latest
entertainment news keep checking back to
ET
online